pour la première fois au monde une
équipe de cardiologues est parvenu à
remplacer la valve pulmonaire
défaillante d'un jeune malade sans
opérée à coeur ouvert
les chirurgiens de l'hôpital necker à
paris ont réussi à poser une prothèse
par voie transcutanée une avancée
médicale qui pourrait concerner 20000
personnes dans les prochaines années
les explications de sylvain le kent et
marque doux à première vue cette valve
pulmonaire n'a rien de particulier
pourtant elle a été implantée sans avoir
à ouvrir le coeur du patient
ce procédé imaginé par le docteur
bonhoeffer le cardiologue allemand qui
travaille depuis six ans à necker a
réalisé une première mondiale en
remplaçons selon cette méthode la valve
défaillante d'un enfant de 12 ans chez
cet enfant c'était le moment de le
libérer pour la quatrième fois la
réouverture du de la poitrine répétées
et bien sûr un problème par pour les
chirurgiens parce que ça donne des
adhérents ça donne beaucoup de
cicatrices et c'est difficile de bréhat
la poitrine et chaque fois de plus que
pour le faire le risque augmente
la technique consiste d'abord à
compresser cette valve pulmonaire avant
de la poudre sur un ressort pour la
faire parvenir enfin jusqu'au coeur par
la veine fémorale
lorsque cette valve se détériorera selon
les cardiologues
il devrait être possible toujours par
voie fémorale dont poser une plus petite
qui pourra s'insérer à l'intérieur de la
précédente
en france chaque année un millier
d'enfants naissent avec ce type de
lésions cardiaques et le nombre de
candidats potentiels à cette valve
ulation selon les cardiologues
s'élèverait en tout
à près de 20 mille patients